they say all you need is love they also
say age ain't nothing but a number but
every so often when you're watching a
movie you see a mismatched couple or
lovestruck criminal taking things too
far here are some of the most
uncomfortable age gaps in movies that's
my boy even if you're a huge Adam
Sandler fan you've got to admit that he
didn't just cross a line and that's my
boy he straight-up pole-vaulted over
that sucker if the premise of this 2012
comedy is utterly tasteless as its
involves a tween version of sunless
character having sex with his teacher
just to be clear we're talking about a
12 year old boy being coerced into
having sex with an adult resulting in a
pregnancy all played as a joke
considering that my boy only has a 20
percent on Rotten Tomatoes and the
totally flopped at the box office it
seems like the joke's on Sandler and his
crude crow burger the 1988 comedy
classic burger follows a kid named Josh
who magically morphs into a 30 year old
man at first this transformation seems
pretty cool especially when josh has
paid big bucks to play with toys for a
living but the things get problematic
when he starts dating Susan his adult
co-worker you say glow-in-the-dark
compass ring she won't get lost
true Tom Hanks and Elizabeth Perkins are
about the same age in real life but in
the movie josh is actually only 12 so
when the two end up sleeping together
we're witnessing a serious felony
offense even though Susan doesn't yet
know about Josh's condition it's hard to
wrap your head around true but it's
undeniably creepy at the end when Josh
reversed to his child form and grown
woman Susan waves goodbye to her
twelve-year-old ex-boyfriend American
Beauty Kevin Spacey won the Best Actor
Oscar for playing Lester Burnham in
American Beauty a middle-aged - loser
who's inspired to take control of his
life after falling for a high-school
student making things even worse she's
his daughter's best friend Angela Roger
Ebert noted correctly that the film
wasn't really about a lolita
relationship but instead about yearning
after youth respect power and of course
beauty but Lester's fantasies about
betting a child are of all
saying you can't help but agree with
actress Kirsten Dunst who had the good
sense to turn down the role of Angela
because she quotes didn't want to kiss
Kevin Spacey or be seen lying naked in
those rose petals after all she was only
15 Leon at the professional French
director Luc Besson's 1994 action flick
Leon the professional is a movie that'll
leave you feeling a little odd while the
relationship between genre knows Leon
and Natalie Portman's Matilda isn't
appropriate per se it is just a tad
disconcerting the plot involves a
twelve-year-old girl who asks a hit man
to get revenge on the psychotic DEA
agent who murdered her family Leon and
Matilda's relationship starts off
strange
he's childlike she's wise for her years
and only gets weirder from there
[Music]
especially when she starts crushing on
Leon and telling strangers as full grown
man as her lover
despite Leon always keeping things
professional the Diary of a teenage girl
based on the acclaimed graphic novel The
Diary of a teenage girl is meant to push
boundaries and start conversations after
all this is a film about a 15 year old
girl discovering her sexuality a subject
that's rarely discussed on the big
screen
however some might argue that diary
takes things a bit far when its teenage
protagonists winds up in bed with a 35
year old man the 15 year old in question
is played by Belle Polly who was
actually in her twenties while filming
she's a wannabe cartoonist in 1976 who
loses her virginity to her mom's
boyfriend Munro played by Alexander
Skarsgard as critic 8 er er bland points
out this is a movie about a girl in
control and making our own decisions
even if they're probably bad ones and
watching the consequences of those bad
decisions however poignantly they're
portrayed will likely make you squirm
Harold and Maude perhaps the most famous
movie ever about may-december
relationships Harold and Maude was a
box-office failure in 1971 but over the
years it's gained a cult following today
it's often considered must watch cinema
although if you're only familiar with
the basic premise you might think this
is a film simply about a kid who sleeps
with
woman old enough to be is grandma of
course Harold and Maude isn't just about
the sex we don't even see anything
happen on screen the film follows
death-obsessed Harold a 20 year old who
faked suicide and visits random funerals
eventually he runs into the
larger-than-life mod a 79 year old who
teaches Harold how to really live
[Music]
Manhattan 1979's Manhattan is widely
considered to be one of the greatest
movies ever made but it's also a film
about Woody Allen having a fling with a
17 year old Alan plays a 40-something
comedy writer that has no qualms being
involved with a high school girl played
by Mary or Hemingway he even finds it
amusing when she ends a date because she
has to study for a test you'll have a
dozen relationships believe me far more
passionate in this one the events of the
film followed Hemingway into real life
the actress says after she turned 18
Alan showed up at her house and
allegedly asked her parents to let her
accompany him to Paris she said no in
the late 1980s Alan began a relationship
with his longtime girlfriend Mia
Farrow's adopted daughter soon-yi Previn
who later became his wife
Lolita Lolita is often hailed as one of
the best novels of the 20th century but
it's not exactly what you'd call light
reading nevertheless the dark and
twisted novel inspired two separate
movies Stanley Kubrick's 1962 version
starring James Mason and sue Lyon and
Adrienne lines 1997 version featuring
Jeremy Irons and Dominique Swain both
movies focus on Humbert Humberts a
self-proclaimed a nympho file who is
only sexually attracted to
post-pubescent teen girls who meet her
specific criteria both lion and Swain
were actually 14 and 15 respectively
so naturally displaying the subject
matter on screen has stirred up a lot of
controversy Kubrick's version is far
tamer than lions but it still made a lot
of people uncomfortable prompting the
now classic a question how did they ever
make a movie of the liter thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel
us check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]